and now boycott
the beijing games that's the focus of
tonight's angle
the following are indisputable facts
china
is a brutal dictatorship a repressive
regime
china does not recognize individual
freedom
freedom to worship speak freely to
petition the government
fact china has imprisoned and tortured
political dissidents
christians and currently has more than a
million uyghur muslims
in re-education camps so how does
china keep its citizens in line 1.3
billion well through intimidation and
fear that's for sure
and a vast surveillance network
according to the bbc
by 2018 there were already about 200
million surveillance cameras in china
and by 2021 this number is expected to
reach
560 million roughly
one for every 2.4 citizens
now peaceful protesters in hong kong
they tried their best to avoid being
caught on surveillance cameras they
could bow down and kind of
walk below them but mask wearing was
probably a bigger
help than their camera dodging
and china's aggressive ambitions aren't
limited to its own borders of course or
to asia
they want the entire world with america
being the crown jewel
dominating america means defeating us
economically
and to advance that goal they're
infiltrating american educational
institutions
now one estimate puts the number of
chinese students studying in the united
states
at a staggering 350 000
and it's no exaggeration to say that our
colleges and our universities
have become infested with ccp agents
one recent example is the university of
texas professor
who the feds accused of stealing
proprietary technology
from a u.s tech startup and handing it
over to the ccp
controlled huawei late last year dhs
warned that chinese-made drones were
providing u.s
critical infrastructure and law
enforcement data
to the chinese government well now what
does the ccp want
that data for what do they plan to do
with it huh
for its part the eu strat for cash and
desperate for funds to support its
struggling economies
it doesn't seem to care that much about
human rights in china
the chinese president spoke yesterday
and he and i
agree on that we see a need for
multilateralism
we need to find a new mode of
cooperation between states
basically to go back to an efficient
brand of multi-natural
lateralism america is back
diplomacy is back at the center of our
foreign policy
america is back ready to lead the world
well translation appeasement is upon us
and it's funny though they never seem to
hesitate
when it's time to criticize us the
voters right they have no problem
criticizing people who believe
in america first or anti-globalization
but
china no they back away how are they
going to lead the world
if it has to go hat in hand to an evil
regime like
china that's not leading that's giving
in
joe biden claims that you know america
is back and he wants to be the world
leader
well if that's really true he should
start
by announcing a boycott of the 2022
winter games in beijing
and then convince our allies in europe
and elsewhere to join the boycott
when the olympic committee let hitler
host the 1936 games in berlin
it was a dark stain on the games that
lasted for decades
it was just big propaganda a coup for
the nazis
and it's going to be the exact same for
the chinese communists
imagine president xi walking into that
stadium for the first time
lording over the crowd packed in tight
to show that the decadent west
uh boy you guys haven't overcome covid
but we have with his
air of superiority now if we're there if
the united states is there
the ccp will just argue that our
complaints about human rights they don't
really mean anything we just say that we
mow the words
that we're just too weak to resist china
that we'll always do what we're told
and many observers around the world i'm
afraid will agree
now in the past we've had presidents who
were brave enough to take on rogue
regimes
heck if jimmy carter could stand up to
the ussr in 1980
biden can stand up to the ccp today
but i'm not holding my breath for most
of his career
old joe has defended china from its
critics
and he's still doing so the idea i'm not
going to speak
out against what he's doing in hong kong
what he's doing with the uyghurs in
western
mountains of of uh china and taiwan
trying to end the one china policy by
making it forceful
he gets it culturally there are
different
norms that each country and they their
leaders are expected to follow
just different cultural norms that whole
thing they're doing with the uyghurs but
i'll mouth the words
you see what he did there now of course
establishment figures such as
mitt romney well they're pushing back on
the idea of a boycott claiming
it would punish our athletes now to be
blunt
that's just pathetic the angle of course
empathizes with athletes we love the
athletes who participate in the games
and they've trained so hard to compete
and of course the ioc the problem is
they never should have awarded the games
to china in the first place
but rewarding china after its actions
surrounding the virus
and its gross human rights abuses it's
not an
option china is desperately seeking
legitimacy on the world stage
and we should not give it to them now of
course corporate america has no problem
being associated with china
we know that from what nike's done this
is a list of u.s companies who
are top-tier sponsors for the 2020 games
it's a big one now the cato institute's
doug bandau
also disagrees with the boycott as well
he argues that
a solitary or almost solitary holdout by
the u.s
might make some feel righteous but it
would likely be counterproductive
a unitary action would highlight
america's isolation
beijing would feel emboldened more
convinced that no one was prepared to
confront
even its worst behavior well his
arguments are kind of
unpersuasive the boycott would show the
world that we're not going to treat
china as a normal country any longer
perhaps we couldn't convince
you know some of our allies to join the
boycott but they probably side with
china no matter what we did
at least we wouldn't be selling out our
own principles doesn't that count for
something
the bind administration has apparently
not made reportedly a final decision on
china again that's what they claim
but regardless of what the us government
and the international olympic committee
decide to do
we as consumers should all refuse to
watch the games
the ioc gets an enormous amount of money
for the u.s tv
rights and we need to show nbc and the
ioc that those rights
will be worthless if they insist on
acting
as a ccp promoter or a legitimizer
allowing china to become the world's
most powerful country
was a catastrophic failure of u.s policy
making
with blame from everyone from george h.w
bush
to joe biden but if we want to remain
independent ourselves we americans are
going to have to get used to the idea
of sometimes being a lonely beacon for
freedom in the world
a world dominated now by dictatorships
and technocrats
the 2022 olympics would be a good place
to start